savez vous pourquoi il ya plusieurs
travailleurs de la santé qui sont tannés
de se faire rappeler ange gardien on
n'est pas des anges descendu du ciel qui
peuvent voler qui peuvent faire des
miracles on ne peut pas faire des
miracles au relais des humains parce
qu'à mesure que l'espoir renaît d'un
retour à la vie normale on est peut-être
collectivement en train d'oublier ceux
et surtout celles qui nous ont permis de
la traverser cette crise j'adore mon
travail mais j'ai pas demandé de le
faire dans une pandémie mondiale pendant
un homme qui prend soin des gens qui ont
tant pris soin de nous je tenterai de
m'épuiser am chercher de l'année le
gouvernement faut qu'il le ministère les
sus il faut qu'ils réalisent le tsunami
de problèmes de santé mentale qui s'en
met ici marie maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
9 janvier 20h on est au plus fort de la
deuxième vague mais les plus difficiles
ça va régler
vodka prochaines mois à ce jour le corps
un navire russe a contaminé près de 200
et 1000 québécois
plus de 1700 ans omar pour diminuer la
pression sur le système de santé
on décrète un deuxième confinement et on
n'est pas une mesure historique extrême
un couvre feu
on va voir un couvre-feu au québec
de 8 heures le soir à 5h le matin le
québec fond noir
les mesures ont un impact négatif sur la
santé mentale
derrière les portes closes la détresse
gagne du terrain il
l'éclosion fake it on doit encore à
nouveau fermé la porte aux gens c'est
vraiment encore la même image devant
protéger l'intérieur le puits fermé les
portes d'un bon coeur à ça chaque et
déjà l'extérieur à qui on répond pas et
qui sont pas plus en sécurité comme une
vague un peu soudaine ou est ce que je
me sentais complètement le paralyser ou
fatalité ou pour moi c'était comme
fallait vraiment que je fasse de poids
mais je savais pas quoi faire
j'avais l'impression qu'ils avaient
quelque chose d'imminent qui me qui
allait m'arriver mais que j'avais pas de
hussein et elles arrivent dans un état
qui beaucoup plus critique beaucoup plus
d'émotions beaucoup plus d'impulsivité
beaucoup plus de sévérité
les intervenants ont dû faire face à
deux tentatives de suicide ne serait-ce
qu'en l'espace de ces cinq derniers
jours
si c'est des images qui n'ont jamais de
sortir de la tête des gens qui c'est qui
qui se battent pour respirer gens c'est
ce que j'aimerais que le monde comprenne
mieux il n'y avait rien d'anormal dans
qu'est ce qu'on a vécu pendant des mois
la détresse des québécoises ont monté en
flèche
plus que jamais le manque de ressources
en santé mentale va faire
très mal
[Musique]
il est 11 heures les gens étaient
positifs dans la rue parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de services adaptés c'est
pas la faute à personne mais les fortes
y est plongé dans une course contre la
montre pour s'ajuster à une mesure
inédite le gouvernement le goût est sur
le point d'annoncer un couvre-feu qui
placera des centaines de personnes en
situation d'itinérance dans l'illégalité
elle a moins de 24 heures pour mettre en
place un plan d'urgence au pavillon pour
hommes de la mission au bruit ou elle
est directrice des services pour la
deuxième fois en un
elle doit annuler le service de repas
qui nourrissait jusqu'à 800 personnes
chaque jour avant la pandémie
une halte chaleur d'habitude ouvertes
toute la nuit durant l'hiver pour fermer
ses portes à 19 heures en plus comme
c'est le cas depuis le début de la
pandémie
la moitié des 280 4 lits et de refuges
doivent rester vides
il ya un groupe de la population les
plus marginalisés les consommateurs ceux
qui ont des plans de santé mentale
vraiment la population de rue qui
fréquentaient plus les attaches à
l'heure ou qui sont dans un autre mode
de vie complètement eux et il ya
certains services qui répondent à leurs
besoins mais eux pour eux ils manquent
de la place est là avec le couvre feu
lui rien qui va s'améliorer
nécessairement
c'est ici à la place émilie gamelin que
ceux qui n'ont nulle part où aller se
retrouve à la tombée de la nuit
en quelques mois ils ont survécu au
démantèlement de leur campement à les
110 de leur hébergement d'urgence
le jour de noël ont plus de voir l'un
des leurs ou mourir de froid dans un
toilette chimique tous prennent un
refuge perd mais c'est sans compter une
augmentation des surdoses après qu'on
ait limité les places et les heures
d'ouverture des centres d'injection
supervisés en fait c'est qu'on brise
maintien c'est notre seul moyen d'avoir
de pouvoir aider ces personnes là c'est
de maintenir un lien d'un coup que nous
on est fermé on n'est plus le lien avec
eux et c'est des gens que l'état peut
déférer rapidement aussi notre objectif
c'est que tout le monde aille en réseau
de sécurité un filet de sécurité autour
d'eux et là on interrompt le filet de
sécurité dans ce personnage se ramasse
dans la rue désorganisés il les a
demandé intervention policière en place
hier ce qui est pas bien fait ça va 30
et aux passes éteindre des feux prendre
des décisions difficiles à la dernière
minute avec des ressources de plus en
plus il tue deux mois jean les femmes
seraient pas intello là c'est devenu le
quotidien des midis fortier et de
centaines d'intervenants communautaire
qui tente tant bien que mal d'aider
leurs clients en crise malgré les
mesures sanitaires en place
merci après un an dans l'urgence ils
sont à bout de souffle je pense pas que
les gens je serai elysées à quel point
on exige hauteur au milieu communautaire
que à la santé publique qu'un
gouvernement qui a des policiers tous
ceux qui sont impliqués dans l'urgence
après santander
plus tard le 20 janvier
l'album des décisions difficiles
emilie fortier a aussi dû en faire à la
maison en première vague débordé au
travail
elle a envoyé son fils adam vivre chez
ses parents et là à peine vu pendant
près de deux mois
ça commençait au niveau du rôle de la
mère c'est sûr que où ça en est à 9
ça fait que mon raison ce qui re télé
des personnes sur qui je peux compter
sur mes parents j'ai mon goût d'un côté
et de l'autre côté il ya une crise qui
met en danger la vie de personne et mon
gars je peux le mettre en sécurité avec
mes parents et mes cd d'un constat sur
elle est où la limite de emilie versus
la limite la directrice et son rôle
c'est quoi l'impact sur mon fils ma
famille et la vie personnelle on la
laisse de côté je sollicitais au travail
des 12 16 ans par jour je peux pas gérer
une routine d'un enfant de neuf ans il
le comprend bien
je crois j'espère qu'ils vont me
pardonner
un jour qu'il doit pas traîner ce toutes
ces villes mais on n'a pas le choix je
pense
ça m'est arrivé de dire j'ai pas demandé
ses rôles et tu peux demander d'être
j'adore mon travail mais j'ai pas
demandé de le faire dans une pandémie
mondiale
donc il pendant une heure mais ils ont
seulement si les clauses ont été
contenus tout le monde veut faire comme
en première main qui a arrêté toutes les
éditions ce qui va vous permettre bien
étant petit
pourquoi moi lui pourquoi le jeu doit
prendre cette décision
après si tu l'apprends on l'assumé on
organise et leurs yeux l'on passe à
autre chose
ne pas très longtemps pour se remettre
en question en fertilité on prend la
décision il faut passer à autre chose
parce que sinon ça va bien retourné faux
répond très bien je pense comme toi bien
là bas
un rythme effréné qu'on retrouve dans
certaines données liées à la santé
mentale au canada et au québec que nous
avons compilé depuis le début de la
pandémie
le nombre d'appels reçus par les
services téléphoniques de soutien
psychologique a grimpé en flèche les
demandes aide aux services de prévention
du suicide du canada ont plus que doublé
[Musique]
les interventions policières liés à des
situations non criminelle incluant les
surdoses les conflits familiaux et les
tentatives de suicide ont augmenté de 9%
comparé à l'année précédente
les interventions liées à des problèmes
de santé mentale ont bondi de 13 pour ça
[Musique]
entre mars et septembre 2020 les
demandes de remboursement pour des
antidépresseurs au pays ont augmenté de
3% comparé à la même période en 2010 9
au québec c'est 25000 personnes de plus
que l'an dernier qui se sont fait
prescrire des antidépresseurs
la hausse la plus significative est chez
les aînés de 65 ans et plus on rapporte
8 % plus de prescription que l'année
précédente malgré une plus grande
détresse
la peur du virus a tenu les québécois à
l'écart des hôpitaux les visites aux
urgences pour problèmes psychologiques
ont baissé tout comme les visites dans
les urgences des hôpitaux psy qui a pris
ces chiffres ne reflètent toutefois
qu'une partie de la réalité de cette
pandémie
c'est la pointe de l'iceberg de la
hausse beaucoup plus importante qu'on
observe à travers nos enquêtes
populationnelle au niveau de la santé
psychologique depuis un an
la chercheuse mélissa généreux documente
l'état de santé mentale de plus de 10000
québécois en février dernier une
personne sur quatre rapportait des
symptômes d'anxiété ou de dépression à
montréal c'était une personne sur 3 6 %
des répondants rapporté avoir des idées
suicidaires deux fois plus qu'avant la
pandémie pourtant une minorité a demandé
de l'aide
ces sommes à 35 % d'entre eux qui nous
disent avoir consulté pour cette raison
là alors que clairement selon les
symptômes qui le rapport il aurait dû où
on peut s'arrêter bénéfique ça a été
très pertinent qu'il consulte et même
pour ce qui est des idées suicidaires
sérieuse les gens qui disent oui j'ai
songé sérieusement à me suicider dans la
dernière année
mais c'est seulement la moitié d'entre
eux qui disent ah est allé chercher un
soutien pyschologique au cours de la
dernière année
pour moi c'est parfait je souhaite une
bonne soirée
ce qu'ils ont appelé à l'aide se sont
beaucoup tourné vers les organismes
communautaires en santé mentale
plutôt que vers le réseau public comment
ces organismes chroniquement
sous-financé ont-ils géré cette nouvelle
vague de détresse après la pause on vous
fait découvrir la réalité de ceux qui
sont à l'autre bout du fil
quand on appelle à l'aide on est
conscient de ce que nos intervenants en
font tous un peu plus
[Musique]
pour mesurer l'impact de la pandémie sur
la santé mentale des québécois on
analyse et beaucoup de données des
appels à la ligne 8 1 1 la ligne info
social
vous allez voir que ce qui se passe à la
télévision avait un impact immédiat sur
les demandes aide et sur ceux qui sont
là pour les écouter
puis qu'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu pourrais faire pour
pour prendre soin de toi on va boucler
une évaluation à venir rencontrer
quelqu'un ici c'est souvent dans des
organismes comme celui ci au centre
ville de montréal que son référé les
personnes en crise
24 heures sur 24
le transit répondent aux appels de
détresse et sert de refuge d'urgence
ces personnes l'attendent au dernier
moment pour nous appeler donc elles
arrivent dans un état qui est beaucoup
plus critique beaucoup plus d'émotions
beaucoup plus vite d'impulsivité
beaucoup plus de sévérité les demandes
aides ont bondi au transit
particulièrement depuis l'annnonce de
deuxième confinement près d'un appel sur
cinq proviennent de personnes qui
n'avaient jamais eu recours aux services
auparavant on peut pas le garantir une
place pour la semaine prochaine c'est
vraiment au jour le jour où enfin malgré
les risques de contamination le centre
continue d'ouvrir ses portes aux clients
souvent pour leur éviter d'atterrir à
l'urgence elle pas surcharger son réseau
des jeunes à l'aîné en 2001 et le fil
des gens anxieux dépressifs souvent âgés
de 18 à 30 ans beaucoup souffrent de
troubles du sommeil d'autres consomment
plus d'alcool ou de drogue
dans d'autres cas plus graves on note
une hausse de la violence domestique et
des idées suicidaires
bah oui à l'enam et rabat le plan on a
vu appeler plus fréquemment les
étudiants notamment les personnes
immigrantes
je vous dirais qu'on a vu aussi beaucoup
de personnes en situation de détresse
périnatale il n'y a pas que la peur du
virus l'isolement-- les mesures
sanitaires sévère qui inquiète pour
plusieurs ce qui est le plus stressant
ce sont les messages du gouvernement
bonjour du monde écoutez j'ai voulu
porter de masque pas parce qu on a
besoin ici mais parce que vous avez doit
on faire une suggestion
t'es sûr que nous au niveau de
l'intervention on a dit aussi s'ajuster
par rapport à ça on a dû relayer le
langage aussi du gouvernement parce
qu'on est un service public pour pouvoir
justement solidariser les personnes aux
consignes qui ont été partagées par le
gouvernement dans chaque scénario y des
inconvénients entre autres sur la santé
mentale
quand on suit des nouvelles surtout
quand les cieux en rafale
on les intègre en fait et cette espèce
de l'accumulation de mauvaises nouvelles
un impact vraiment sur la santé mentale
donc oui il ya vraiment il ya vraiment
un lien de cause à effet on va en voir
un couvre-feu
au québec les deux journées de
rassemblement vont être annulées pour
tenter de mesurer l'impact ces annonces
nous nous sommes penchés sur les appels
reçus au service de consultation
téléphonique info social le 8-1-1
si la ligne d'écouté est l'une des
ressources les plus souvent mentionnées
dans les messages du gouvernement
portant sur la santé mentale
si vous éprouvé de la difficulté à
réaliser des actions du quotidien
des solutions existent
la semaine du 15 mars 2020 juste après
l'annnonce de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
la fermeture des écoles et des garderies
la ligne info social est inondée
d'appels en poche de 400 450 affirmé
injuste pour répondre aux lutins de mai
on en ajoute 150 les appels reçus passe
de 7000 par semaine à plus de 11500 les
appels continue de crainte et la semaine
suivante
tous les centres d'achat vont devoir
fermer aussi toutes les salles des
restaurants la ligne reçoit plus de 13
mai l'appel mais les temps d'attentes
pour parler à quelqu'un sont deux fois
plus longue qu'à l'habitude près du
tiers des gens raccroche avant d'y
arriver c'est à montréal qu'on observe
les augmentations les plus dramatiques
les appels ont presque triplé au tout
début du confinement dans le mois
suivant et volume d'appels reste bien
au-dessus de la moyenne
malgré des baisses à l'été et à la
période des fêtes la tendance est encore
vrai ou billy janvier les appels dont 10
de 42% passe même de la manche du
deuxième confinement
[Musique]
c'est très très révélateur dans notre
étude à savoir que c'est pas juste les
allemands ou la part du virus qui vient
conditionné comment les gens 60 au
niveau du moral mais beaucoup la manière
dont ils perçoivent les messages le
niveau de confiance qu'ils ont à voir le
gouvernement
le niveau de confusion ou d'adhésion des
pauses croyances tout seul c'est hyper
prédicteurs dans l'anxiété des pressions
les téléphones se sont aussi mises à
sonner plus que d'habitude dans les 29
centre de prévention du suicide de la
province dans la dernière année
[Musique]
les appels sont plus longs et les
situation plus critique
les normands toujours aidé à l'aise de
valve de ce sujet là celle de nous
appliquer plus récemment ce qui a changé
un peu aussi c'est les appels concernant
les jeunes les plus jeunes alors des
amis qui sont inquiets des parents qui
sont inclus et puis des jeunes ok qui
appellent pour eux-mêmes parce qu'ils
ont des pensées suicidaires
en 2020 la ligue provinciale de
prévention du suicide a reçu quelque
soixante mille appels pendant la
deuxième vague à l'automne 2020 les
intervenants répondait à 20% plus
d'appels selon notre analyse de données
ça veut dire que les gens qui vivent la
détresse qui ont besoin d'un qui pensent
au suicide ou s'inquiète pour un proche
les appels afin de maintenir les
services 24 heures sur 24
plusieurs des intervenants du centre ont
travaillé toute la période des fêtes
en attendant des renforts on est
conscient je veux que nos intervenants
en font tous un peu plus de l'importance
encore une fois nous aurons fort pour
s'assurer que nos intervenants s'épuise
pas ou qui tout simplement parce que la
pression est important le plus grand
défi du centre recruter et retenir le
personnel
le salaire de base d'un intervenants de
première ligne dans un centre de crise
ou de prévention du suicide et de 16 à
18 dollars de l'heure
c'est environ 8 à 10 dollars de moins
que le salaire d'un intervenant
psychosocial du secteur publique à
compétence égale
c'est un travail professionnel qui est
fait dans les centres de prévention du
suicide
et pourtant les salaires jeudi sont
vraiment différents de ceux du réseau
alors ça c'est toujours en inexplicable
etc des revendications de jeudi qui date
alors dans le contexte coville je peux
vous dire que ce c'est réglé je dirais
non absolument pas
offrons parfois sept jours par semaine
des travailleurs de la santé ont été
particulièrement éprouvés dans la
dernière année
et quand ils ont appelé à l'aide ils ont
fait face à eux aussi au manque de
soutien et de services disponibles en
santé mentale
après la pause
elles ont été traumatisés par ce
qu'elles ont vécu en ch et celle des ccd
images ne montrent jamais de sortir de
la parité
[Musique]
on les a qualifiés de héros ont l'art
promis un soutien psychologique à la
hauteur de leur dévouement
mais quand on y regarde de plus près on
se rend compte que beaucoup de
travailleurs de la santé n'ont pas reçu
l'aide dont ils avaient besoin pour
continuer
des applaudissements des percussions des
arcs en ciel pour encourager les
travailleurs est essentielle
partout à travers le monde
[Musique]
une scène quasi quotidiennes dans les
premières semaines de la pandémie
pour ceux qui sont rapidement devenus
des symboles d'espoir et de résilience
vous êtes nos anges gardiens on compte
sur vous faites un travail extra pour
plusieurs travailleurs de la santé être
un ange c'est lourd à porter on n'est
pas des anges descendent du ciel qui
peuvent voler qui peuvent faire des
miracles on ne peut pas faire des
miracles on est des humains et on a
besoin d'eux on a besoin de moyens on a
besoin d'outils on a besoin de soutien
au printemps
nathalie stack est douce et a répondu à
l'appel d'offres lancé par le premier
ministre le go avec la plate forme je
contribue à ce moment là j'ai appliqué
j'ai contribué bauer parce que je
voulais laisser mes collègues je savais
que je pouvais aider j'ai déjà travaillé
en ch et celle des comme préposée et
comme infirmière on l'envoie dans un
siège et celle des en pleine éclosion
elle y travaillera pendant tout le mois
d'avril au plus fort de la tempête
je savais que ce serait difficile mais
malgré mes attentes très très mal si on
veut look très sombre steve mille fois
pire que ce que j'aurais pu imaginer
dans mes pires cauchemars
[Musique]
comme partout ailleurs l'infirmière et
ses collègues cumulent les heures et
manquent de tout jacques est masques
tombent en d'oxygène en quelques
semaines près de 40 % des résidents du
centre d'hébergement meur dont plusieurs
sous ses soins dans mort ça devrait être
beau crise ça devrait être paisible ça
devrait turin ça devrait être sans
boulot ça devrait être entouré de gens
qu'on aime t puis c'était ce qui était
qui était vraiment si c'est des images
qui vont jamais de sortir de la taille
de 2 des gens que c'est qui qui se
battent pour respirer gens ce n'est pas
comme si juste quelqu'un avait pesé face
au world sur les chercher celle du
peuple qui ont juste que tout est comme
normal sauf que il marche un peu plus
vite
non non non non c'est comme si quelqu'un
avait mis une bombe dans l'est ch à
celle des
après un mois d'horreur et d'efforts
elle subi un test de dépistage
elle apprend qu'elle a contractés
lakovic 19 comme plus de 13 mille
travailleurs de la santé durant la
première vague
une fois guérie elle décide finalement
de ne pas retourner au centre
d'hébergement
près d'un an plus tard l'infirmière
d'expérience et toujours hanté par ce
qu'elle a vécu pleurer pour quelque
chose où as tu as l'impression de
chercher son souffle ou pour des
niaiseries le t3 quelque chose passer à
terrible ça fait penser à quelque chose
si tu fais des cauchemars et des choses
comme ça donc c'était plus ma famille
qui me connaissent très bien que c'est
vraiment eux qui m'ont aidé quand même
réalisé que oui ces groupies que c'était
normal d'être bouleversé parce que
qu'est ce que j'avais vécu
[Musique]
je me sentais vraiment comme
pour moi c'était vraiment de la peur
mais que je savais pas vers où la
diriger ont duré j'avais l'impression
qu'il y avait quelque chose d'imminent
qui allait m'arriver mais que j'avais
pas de hausse et venez infirmière depuis
six ans marie-eve lingard leur a
développé une passion pour les patients
en 6 h et celle des je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait j'avais des bonnes
qualités pour travailler surtout avec
les patients qui fonda démence ont fait
la preuve qu'on avait avec les
résidences devaient changer aussi parce
qu'on était dans un milieu de vie fut
qu'on avait l'habitude d'avoir une
familiarité avec nos résidents une
charge même avec nos résidents le
soudainement baye fall et garde à
distance fall élise séparés les uns des
autres
allez ça devenait le contre nature un
peu de ce qu'on fait habituellement
après six semaines dans un centre
d'hébergement en éclosion
marie-eve se blesse au dos son médecin
la place en arrêt de travail
une fois en pause elle constate que ça
ne va pas du tout
[Musique]
en fait je me suis auto évaluer puis je
voyais très bien que mon sommet était
perturbé j'étais très agitée j'étais
très agitée je me sentais aussi au
niveau d'une humeur beaucoup plus
fonction j'avais beaucoup j'étais très
équitable à la maison j'avais des
mauvaises habitudes qui revenait
peut-être ma consommation d'alcool qui
avaient augmenté un petit peu parce que
justement manière de me détendre le soir
et mais j'avais aussi ce ça c'est ça
j'ai beaucoup d'agitation beaucoup de
sommeil qui était devenu très très très
fragile
ces attaques de panique lui qui était
complètement nouvelle pour moi
[Musique]
début novembre plus le choix marie-eve
doit reprendre le travail
quand il affecte dans un nouveau siège
chez ldlc qu'elle ne va pas mieux ça
m'arrivait plus le soir ces moments-là
de panique plutôt ceux ci je me rappelle
à quelques trois fois que j'ai appelé
mon seul mon programme d'ado employés et
une fois donc je n'ai pas été capable de
par la personne après une heure
d'attenté au téléphone
[Musique]
je marchais je prenais démarche en même
temps que j'attendais la ligne met un
peu de baume est calme et puis je veux
rentrer chez moi moment
notre foi ou est-ce que je parle à
quelqu'un une récente est quelqu'un qui
m'a pris la peine mais qui avait pas
d'intervenant pas pour moi que ils y ont
fait un suivi mais comme douze ans plus
tard j'étais au travail je peux en
parler puisque puis le moment il n'y
avait aussi pendant la première règle
avait mis en place je pense une ligne
d'écouté pour les employés le par
rapport à la coved dans mon organisation
mais ça c'était des sur les heures
ouvrables de bureaux du lundi au
vendredi j'ai fait appel mais c'était
comme n'y avait pas de suivi possible
avec ce satané de l'aude plus c'était
comme une ligne ou ce qu'on pourrait
appeler pour ventiler un peu je pense ça
fait comme un peu l'effet d'un un
plaster une hémorragie rapidement et les
coûts les cinq heures de thérapie
offerte par le programme des deux
employées du sus pour lequel elle
travaille à peine retourner au travail
elle apprend qu'elle a contracté la
coved 19 et qu'elle a contaminé son
conjoint et sa belle fille elle passe
toute la période des fêtes malade isolé
dans son sous sol le fait d'avoir
retourné d'avoir contracté la coved ça
ça m'a encore déstabiliser beaucoup
d'amour mais je me sens comme fragiliser
un peu plus qui le chante j'avais plus
de ressources s'est clos honnêtement
j'ai j'ai un peu en fait je savais plus
où me diriger par rapport à ça j'ai eu
droit à trois heures de plus de suivi
via mon programme des deux employés mais
moi ce que je me rends compte c'est que
c'est justement pour moi ça sera pas
suffisant clairement non c'est une
clientèle qui étaient particulièrement
affectées ok donc on sait que une hausse
des demandes de consultation on le
savait pertinemment le qu'il fallait
prendre soin de la santé mentale de ces
gens là christine brouh et présidente de
l'ordre des psychologues du québec
pour elle il est essentiel d'agir
rapidement pour éviter que cette
détresse ne se transforment en problèmes
de santé mentale
à partir du moment où tout est très
significative qui
longtemps puisqu'elle est assez intense
pour t'empêcher de fonctionner ben c'est
là où on se dit ben il faut aller voir
un professionnel qui va être capable
d'examiner qui vont objective et puis là
mais peut-être qu'on va réaliser que
c'est un trouble en tête vous pouvez pas
nécessairement prédire exactement que 1
8 rencontres en huit semaines ça va être
fini
pis non seulement ça mais je vous dirais
que si on se rend compte du besoin de la
personne puis qu'on a commencé à offrir
le traitement et qu'en plus la personne
adhère au traitement puis qu'on sent que
ça valait dépit que le pronostic est bon
ben c'est ça va à l'encontre de
l'éthique professionnelle de le ccl en
mai le gouvernement à débloquer 14
millions pour offrir trois heures de
thérapie supplémentaires au personnel de
la santé moins d'un an plus tard le
ministre délégué à la santé et aux
services sociaux reconnaît que la mesure
est un échec
j'étais le premier surpris du manque
d'impact de cet investissement au niveau
du style des programmes aux aidants aux
employés au programme des deux employés
des problèmes de confidentialité par
exemple qu'on fait que plusieurs n'ont
pas voulu en profiter
on a analysé l'impact dont voix qui lui
seulement 2 % d'augmentation des
demandes
malgré tout le stress et tout le ce
qu'ils ont vécu notre personnel dans le
réseau de la santé
le ministre admet du même souffle que
son équipe ne sait pas combien
d'employés du réseau de la santé ont
démissionné ou sont partis en arrêt de
travail depuis le début de la pandémie
l'information est compilé par chaque
centre intégré de santé et n'est pas
transmise à son ministère
selon nos recherches au moins six des
neufs issus et 6 du grand montréal ont
vu augmenter les arrêts de travail liés
à des raisons psychologiques entre avril
et décembre 2020 ces arrêts de travail
ont bondi en moyenne de 55 % comparé à
la même période en 2010 9 un peu de
talent mouche panne serait d'en parler
d'eux dans un milieu où est-ce qu'on
valorise beaucoup le fait d'être des
tofs des bâtis avec tout le vocable
qu'on use qu'on a eu
j'ai été utilisé beaucoup le dans les
médias on est des héros ou des anges
gardiens c'est lourd à porter tout ça
puis on est pas tous équipés également
pour porter son comme employés du réseau
moi j'ai mes responsabilités auprès de
mes passions auprès de mes collègues
auprès de mon employeur mais mon
employeur aussi des responsabilités
envers nous de nous garder autant que
possible en sécurité de nous donner les
outils qu'on a besoin pour faire notre
travail
[Musique]
après la pause des psychologues doivent
abandonner ce qu'ils aident pour aller
prêter main-forte en ch et celle d
abandonner clientèle sur le plan
déontologique ces anti nature pour un
professionnel de santé quels qu'ils
soient
[Musique]
on n'a jamais autant parlé de santé
mentale que cette année avec des
constats inquiétants sur la
désorganisation du réseau de la santé
alors c'est quoi le plan match pour
l'avenir
[Musique]
31 octobre un homme armé d'un sabre
euros dans les rues du vieux-québec et
attaques des passants au hasard une nuit
d'horreur qui fera deux morts et cinq
blessés
le geste violent d'une personne en
pleine crise de psychose selon plusieurs
experts
huit mois après le début de la crise
l'enjeu de la santé mentale et soude est
projeté à l'avant scène
deux jours plus tard le gouvernement
legault annonce une nouvelle enveloppe
de 100 millions dédiés aux services en
santé mentale est déjà prévu que
j'annonce en ce sens lors de la
prochaine mise à jour économique du 12
novembre
des nouveaux investissements les
circonstances des derniers jours me
pousse à le devancer
québec promet de réduire les listes
d'attentes de recruter des psychologues
du secteur privé et d'investir dans la
prévention du suicide mais nous on est
en train de faire une transformation la
façon dont deux se donnent les services
en santé mentale au québec avec le
programme québécois pour les troubles
mentaux et on veut impliquer plus ces
organismes communautaires la travailler
ensemble cet investissement ne demeure
qu'une goutte d'eau dans un désert de
sous financement qui perdure depuis des
années partout au canada
comme la plupart des provinces
canadiennes le québec vers seulement 6 %
de son budget annuel en santé aux
services en santé mentale
déjà avant la pandémie plus de 25000
québécois étaient en attente d'une
première rencontre avec un psychologue
ou un psychiatre pour arriver à voir un
psychologue dans le réseau public de la
santé
il faut comprendre qu'on n'y arrive pas
directement
en plus d'avoir de plus en plus de
patients il y à aussi de moins en moins
de psychologues par le réseau public
pour les soutenir
au début de 2020 seulement 32 % de tous
les psychologues travailler à temps
plein dans le secteur public incluant
les hôpitaux et les écoles toujours au
début de 2020 le taux horaire d'un
psychologue du secteur public pouvait
aller de 33 à 49 dollars de l'heure
environ deux fois moins que celui de son
collègue au privé mais on sait qu'on a
perdu beaucoup d'effectifs dans le
réseau public et d'un réseau public de
l'éducation
donc il ya beaucoup moins de
psychologues qui en avait et qui se sont
justement pour retourner vers les
cabinets privés
moi je pense que il va falloir l'airé
attirer ces gens là comme plusieurs dans
le milieu de la santé mentale
elle avait tiré la sonnette d'alarmé sur
ce problème au début du premier
confinement il ya beaucoup de
psychologues des centaines de
psychologues qui ont levé la main pour
aider puis pour dire écoutez on va
offrir du soutien
[Musique]
parmi les solutions proposées au
gouvernement déployés des thérapeutes
ancien chez celles des afin d'offrir un
soutien psychologique aux personnels aux
résidents et aux familles endeuillées
québec décide plutôt de réaffecter une
reine 2000 psychologue du réseau public
de la santé et de l'éducation vers des
tâches administratives pour deux
préposés aux bénéficiaires
je pense que pour plusieurs ça a été
déchirée par ce qu'il faut comprendre
que quand on interrompt des services
avec une clientèle qu'on suit on est aux
premières loges puis on les connaît les
effets sur la clientèle on connaît la
vulnérabilité de la clientèle abandonne
une clientèle sur le plan déontologique
ces anti nature pour pour un
professionnel de santé quels qu'ils
soient
le ministre délégué à la santé lionel
carmant et conscient des sacrifices
demandés à ses thérapeutes
ça a été un peu une opération décisions
rapides où on a délesté d'aider des
employés incluant du réseau de santé
mentale vers les verts mous ch et celle
des verts nos hôpitaux dans les mêmes
conditions je pense qu'on n'avait pas le
choix on avait des vies à sauver très
important mais c'est clair qu'elle est
deuxième vague maintenant conserver
mieux de compte quand on se bat et on
n'a pas pris les mêmes décisions
on a dit ce texte est essentielle ni le
ministre carreman ni son ministère
n'était en mesure de nous dire combien
d'employés du secteur public
affecté à la santé mentale ont été
réaffectés ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
été envoyés
nous avons aussi posé la question aux 22
centre intégré de santé de la province
en janvier dernier et 19 centres qui ont
répondu le total s'élève à près de 220
employés mais il pourrait y en avoir
beaucoup d'autres
plusieurs organismes qui les
représentent parle d'un impact massif
sur leurs membres mais étaient eux mêmes
trop délester pour le documenter
ces réaffectations étaient assez
importantes pour qu'en juillet les
présidents de huit ordres professionnels
supplie québec de leur fournir un plan
de rapatriement au plus vite
dans une lettre envoyée au ministre de
la santé est obtenu par enquête
ils dénoncent des interruptions de
service qui perdure disent recevoir des
signaux d'alarmé provenant du terrain et
par le besoin urgent en soins et en
réadaptation
les signataires ajoutent en priorisant
certaines populations plus vulnérables
des besoins criants se sont créés
ailleurs nous on a qu'on commençait
depuis milani précédente à centraliser
les délais d'attentes au niveau du
guichet d'accès avant on n'avait même
pas cette information
donc en voyant les lieux de l'impact de
la pandémie sur l'ailé les délais
d'attentes
on avait une idée à peu près de
commencer à aller au niveau de la santé
mentale
difficile d'évaluer l'impact possible de
cette interruption de service sur la
santé mentale
on sait toutefois qu'à l'automne 2020 la
majorité des 3000 des rappeurs son
départ l'ordre des psychologues
rapportait des symptômes plus graves
chez leurs patients des demandes plus
urgentes et on retour d'anciens clients
dont l'état s'était fragilisée
près de 40% des psychologues interrogés
disaient avoir reçu des demandes de
travailleurs de la santé depuis mars
2020 j'ai tenté trouvait en fait soutien
psychologique ou privés mais après
plusieurs appels je tombais tout le
temps sur la main sur les mêmes messages
qui me disait que ben ils prenaient pas
nouveau prenez pas de nouveaux patients
fait le jeu tu entraînes me puiser à me
chercher de la le gouvernement faut
qu'ils le ministère l'issue il faut
qu'ils réalisent les les tsunamis de
problèmes de santé mentale qui sent bien
seul en plus de titres a ajouté le
risque de syndrome de stress post
traumatique des de troubles de panique
et généreux qui peuvent résulter de la
tragédie qu'on a vécu je gère comprends
pas qu ils pas déjà des plans ou moins
qu'on travaille à planifier à mettre des
ressources en place parce que devant la
détresse collective
le gouvernement veut maintenant miser
sur une thérapie communautaire former
des citoyens qui pourront intervenir
auprès des personnes vulnérables de leur
entourage
j'ai demandé un programme spécifique
d'éclaireurs dans le réseau de la santé
et qu'on va qu'on va combiner avec des
pairs aidants dont on va former des
éclaireurs on va former des pairs
aidants puis j'espère que de cette façon
là on va être capable de venir en aide à
ceux qui en ont besoin
encore une fois au long terme on risque
de voir après la pandémie du stress
post-traumatique ou d'autres types de
problèmes de ce genre dans notre réseau
qu'on veut être prêt de l'espoir
nathalie marie-eve en ont trouvé
mais pas dans le réseau de santé
publique nathalie a pu parler une
intervenant psychosocial à quelques
reprises parce qu'elle participait une
étude sur l'épuisement professionnel
chez les infirmières quant à marie-eve
elle a décidé de s'impliquer dans son
syndicat pour sensibiliser ses collègues
à la détresse psychologique dans son
milieu de travail
elle s'est finalement trouvé une
psychologue au privé
[Musique]
en terminant j'ai envie de vous dire un
petit mot sur un balado convient
d'ajouter à notre série histoire enquête
çà s'appelle retour aux sources
et c'est la petite histoire des
reportages que je réalisais avec
plusieurs collègues de l'émission sur
l'industrie de la construction
la collusion la corruption le crime
organisé et bref ça se veut un hommage
aux personnes les plus précieuses pour
cette émission c'est à dire nos sources
de l' enveloppe brune à la cour suprême
pour les protéger je vais vous raconter
cette relation très particulière entre
les journalistes d' enquêtes et ceux qui
nous mettent sur les bonnes pistes
c'est sur la plate forme audio de radio
canada
c'est tout pour ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
revenez nous la semaine prochaine pour
une autre enquête
[Musique]